bonjour à tous la tempête a perturbé la
rentrée des classes dans certains
établissements les élèves du collège
paul bert d'evreux ne rentrerons ainsi
que lundi prochain
si tous les bâtiments sont réparés ap
intervilles dans l'eure les enfants de
maternelle et de primaire n'ont pas pu
rentrer mardi dernier comme prévu mais
ce matin françois verly et max pistolesi
étaient présents intervilles n'en a pas
totalement fini avec les inondations
certains habitants ont encore les pieds
dans l'eau mais l'école elle est
désormais bien au sec
oubliez les 20 cm d'eau dans la cour ce
matin l'établissement a réouvert ses
portes
une rentrée différée sans émotion
particulière
c'est arrivé en 95 et c'est qu'un un peu
plus haut bon là c'était un peu moins
important mais bon c'était quand même
quelque chose je vais les faire parler
et puis ensuite géré sur quoi je vais
axer la discussion très particulièrement
selon sue l'ont peut-être les rides le
traumatisme que tu es bien subi je ne
sais pas du tout je sais pas du tout
comment ça a été vécu ce dépend aussi
beaucoup des parents donc on va voir
les 112 a mis un petit peu plus clair
les 3
magnusson pinterville les enfants renou
petit à petit avec leur ordinaire
l'année scolaire 2001 et désormais bien
en place